the personnel of the scp foundation are
proud highly trained professionals they
are selected from the best of the best
from universities and militaries across
the world the researchers agents and
soldiers that do the daily work of
securing containing and protecting the
world from anomalies take their duties
very seriously when the fate of millions
potentially relies on your daily
decision making things can be a little
intense to say the least kind of makes
you want to take back that old uber
driving gig now doesn't it but with the
massive amounts of personnel the
foundation hires it's inevitable that
not every employee lives up to this high
standard in fact sometimes they
purposefully subvert the standard
whether it be for personal gain power or
something else entirely the consequences
of exploiting their position is often
dangerous
scp-321 is living if you can call it
that evidence of one such incident the
file itself is heavily classified in
fact it's been personally redacted by
05-12 one of the 13 mysterious overseers
that control the day-to-day operations
of the foundation as for why that will
eventually become clear in fact it's so
heavily classified and hidden from main
foundation servers that it isn't even
possible to show it here in its full
state but that doesn't matter anyway
because scp-321 isn't the kind of thing
you can read it's so visceral
you need to see it to believe it so put
on your lab coat and get your clearance
card we're going down into the bowels of
site-04 to find out just what this
strange anomaly is that an overseer is
so insistent on hiding it from the world
imagine you've been working at the
foundation for several years you've seen
all the famous anomalies you've taken
tissue samples from scp-682
you've conducted material tests with
scp-914
and you even interviewed scp-049
all the other researchers have shown you
the ropes but you've more than surpassed
them your superiors have taken notice
that you have a good clean track record
with intelligent and humanoid anomalies
you've recently been promoted from
junior researcher to a full-fledged
foundation researcher and your clearance
class has gone up you can now access
files for most anomalies in the course
of your duties but working at the scp
foundation isn't all fun and games
there's a whole lot of paperwork to fill
out paperwork for tests paperwork for
new anomalies paperwork for every little
containment update whether it be a
dietary change or completely altering an
anomaly's containment method you've
spent long long hours between meetings
or tests in your office at your
foundation issue terminal pouring over
scp files and documents to print out or
put together briefings on during one of
these late night work sessions having
gone down a rabbit hole into scps filed
under reanimation and humanoid tags you
encounter a hyperlink to the file for
scp-321 mildly intrigued at the
memorable number you click it only to be
caught off guard entirely when your
terminal freezes up the screen locks up
and a single message flashes on the
screen unauthorized access automatically
shutting down
the machine reboots itself and seems
fine but you're startled by the
experience though obviously it's not
unheard of sometimes documents in the
foundation are just locked up and people
forget to make a note of it this scp-321
must be just another file nothing to
worry about you know that but that
doesn't stop you from sleeping with the
lights on in your dormitory that night
the next morning when you report the
incident to your supervisor she seems
disinterested she assures you that it
was just a minor unauthorized access
hiccup it happens all the time within
the database but when she asks you what
file it was out of curiosity and you
respond with the number scp-321
well her response is
odd she quietly writes something down
muttering something about adam and
curtly dismisses you to get back to work
it is a curious mystery but it stays a
mystery and you don't hear about scp-321
again for a long time it's years later
you've participated in hundreds more
research inquiries and thousands of
tests and experiments since your skill
with anomalies is pretty notable in
site-04 now and you stand out in a crowd
your position rises appropriately
congratulations you've made senior
researcher very few ever get to this
position much less at your age you
supervise research over dozens of
anomalies and over a hundred staff
though you don't do much testing with
your own hands anymore it's too risky to
send senior researchers in for grunt
work and your role is mostly one of
oversight and supervising so when you
receive an email one late night on your
terminal for containment procedures of
some anomaly you've never heard of
you're not too surprised but when you
read the subject line that changes
scp-321
the same mysterious anomaly that nearly
bricked your terminal when you were just
a researcher you're now about to find
out what was so secret that it needed to
be restricted so heavily you click the
email holding your breath and find
nothing no description of the anomaly no
addendums and certainly no images or
supplements just a partially filled out
scp document item number 3890 object
class safe all that's there is a sparse
set of containment procedures
scp-321 is to be kept in a regulation
containment chamber
scp-321 has been outfitted with
extensive braces to make up for
weaknesses in bone structure and muscle
mass its artificial heart is to be
examined once a month for any damage
scp-321 is to be fed three times daily
solid foods are excluded from its
prescribed diet three staff members are
on temporary scp-321 assignment at this
time
scp-321 is to be given three hours a day
of exercise and physical therapy with
the rest of its time not involved in
experiments to be confined to its cell
while scp-321 is incapable of asking for
anything it has been allowed several
stuffed toys
very very strange it seems to be some
kind of humanoid anomaly but it's not
clear whether it's sentient or not it
also seems remarkably fragile with all
sorts of medical shunts and splints to
counteract extensive calcium deficiency
in the bones and atrophied muscles and
an artificial heart lots of resources
are being spent on keeping this thing
whatever it is alive but what kind of
life does it live not even being able to
eat properly and needing constant
physical therapy between experiments the
stuffed animal thing is even more
haunting stuffed animals are something
the foundation tends to reserve for
child anomalies and why can't it request
anything
all you can conclude is that the
foundation is for whatever reason
keeping a fragile mute child in the
maximum security wing of site-04 and not
letting anyone know about it it's not a
pleasant thought but you know that these
things aren't done for no reason
whatever this anomaly is it likely poses
a danger to itself or people around it
and needs this level of security you
approve the containment procedures close
your email and go to sleep and once
again that's all you hear of scp-321
whatever it is for a very long time site
director is an incredibly prestigious
position in the foundation these titans
manage massive foundation installations
and facilities they're the executives
the big shots the decision makers where
the buck stops some maintain the
researcher routes they came from and
others fall fully into the role of power
player in the foundation's complicated
internal politics either way it's a very
high level of power most people never
get anywhere near when you made
assistance site director you know it's
not the real thing and that getting up
there is still a few years off but that
doesn't stop you from feeling incredibly
proud of how far you've come in your
career at the foundation how many
breaches you've stopped and lives you've
saved by keeping dangerous anomalies
locked up you can access the full
database file on nearly every scp in the
site's catalog now it doesn't take long
before you think back to the strange
anomaly that had repeatedly cropped up
in your career and decide to now bury
the mystery you check in with your
credentials and navigate to the scp-321
file to see what's what it's just your
luck that the database file is
completely empty all that's there are
the same containment procedures you
authorized so many years ago and a short
message from raisa that the scp-321 file
hasn't been digitized yet and that a
physical copy is available in
scp-321's containment chamber strange
but at least now you have somewhere to
go
scp-321's chamber is deep deep below
site-04 it takes you three elevators and
security checkpoints to even get down
there this is where the top secret
anomalies are kept not necessarily
dangerous but the things the foundation
would prefer not to get out to even
their own employees it's a dark hallway
lined with steel doors you find the
right door and scan your card and a
guard waves you in you're in an
observation room of some kind with one
large window looking out into an
adjoining containment chamber there's
computer screens all over the walls
displaying medical information and data
there's no one else in the room but
something is lying in the hospital bed
in the containment chamber there's a
clipboard hanging from the wall bearing
the designation scp-321
you pick it up and carry it with you as
you enter the containment chamber and
approach the hospital bed
scp-321 lies in the bed it's a long
distended looking humanoid almost 10
feet in length but incredibly thin and
frail looking its hair is thinning and
the skin is taut around its face but you
can discern some decidedly feminine
looking features its eyes are closed the
thing is asleep and you give it a closer
look as you cross check it with its
documentation
scp-321 is a human female born sometime
in the 1800s
scp-321 is currently 3.1 meters tall and
weighs approximately 110 kilograms
subject is devoid of melanins in hair
eyes and skin yep that checks out the
anomaly is white as a ghost the document
says that it can't speak and seems to
have trouble with spatial recognition
intelligence and awareness like a child
then then it hits you this thing must be
from the 19th century the next paragraph
is redacted but the one after that is
fascinating you look at it as you circle
scp-321's bed it has complex
regeneration abilities and is capable of
healing injuries and wounds five times
faster than a normal person it ages
incredibly slowly which makes sense it
should be dead by now if it was born
well over a century ago it's noted down
that its aging has stopped entirely but
it keeps growing taller and larger
despite being already over 10 feet tall
well past the point where its heart
should have given out in fact its heart
did give out somewhere in the 20th
century it became too tall for its heart
to properly circulate blood to it this
is the same condition that results in
genetic giants dying so young but
scp-321 was restrained by the foundation
to ensure blood kept flowing to its
brain though this was a losing battle
its healing factor was unable to repair
tissue damage happening constantly and
in real time decay and necrosis began to
set into its muscles and organs the
foundation stepped in just after world
war ii a team of researchers began
working to create a sort of artificial
heart that would allow
scp-321 to keep on pumping blood not to
unlike the modern pacemaker device
actually it was finished some years
later had an expert trained team of
foundation surgeons were tasked with
implementing it since they successfully
completed the operation all of scp-321's
internal damage has healed perfectly
more tests revealed that it's remarkably
recuperative abilities came from an
abundance of stem cells after exposure
to an anomaly after
death you look back up at the thing and
back down is this a practical joke of
some kind you've seen stranger things
than this but still a zombie but it
doesn't seem to be a zombie though it is
undead it's still human at least
apparently it's been taught to eat and
play with some toys as well as exercise
itself though it took researchers years
to train it to do so they've also
figured out that its vocal cords are
intact but for whatever reason it can't
learn to speak just crying and babbling
like an infant the remaining two
paragraphs are under the subheader
origin but they are again redacted in
marker and attributed to the office of
05-12
for some reason where this strange
undead woman came from is a highly
guarded secret that 05-12 doesn't want
getting out very very strange but
ultimately this is all you can do for
now obviously this thing is egging out a
pitiful existence down here who knows if
it's even self-conscious if it can feel
pain it's unfortunate and depressing but
after so many years in the upper
echelons of the foundation's research
staff you've seen some terrible terrible
things this is very sad but what can you
do the heart monitor in the room
continues beeping as you hang up the
clipboard in the observation room and
take your leave it really doesn't
surprise anyone when you eventually
become site director just a few short
years later you're given a warm welcome
into the new job but there's really no
time to relax at all running a
foundation site is busy work lots of
meetings and important briefings to be
had which is how you find yourself
heading to a meeting in the site with
05-12
one of the strange mysterious o5s that
rule the foundation with an iron fist
subject to no one but the ethics
committee what could he possibly want
with you not to mention the fact that
this meeting is in none other than
scp-321's containment chamber when you
arrive you catch a glimpse of him he's
an incredibly old looking man healthy
but leaning on a cane you make small
talk for a moment before he starts
talking about the anomaly lying in the
hospital bed in front of you two he
explains that over a century ago a
foundation junior researcher named adam
had developed a relationship with one of
his colleagues a doctor named evelyn the
rules regarding relationships between
co-workers were much looser than and
they married each other not long after
they even had a child together at least
they were going to unfortunately tragedy
struck not long after evelyn became
pregnant the infant didn't make it and
was stillborn but adam unwilling to give
up began to conduct experiments on the
corpse using scp-590 another one of
adam's anomalous children named tj and a
number of other scps he somehow managed
to bring what remained of his daughter
back to life well to something
resembling life but the foundation
quickly intervened when they discovered
what adam had created they collected the
creature and began to examine and
experiment on her which is when they
discovered her amazing ability to heal
from practically any wound she was
quickly classified as cp321 and placed
into containment for experimentation but
adam was still a junior researcher at
the foundation and he knew his daughter
was undergoing cruel and invasive
experimentation he couldn't live with
the guilt first of losing his wife then
his daughter he made several formal
requests for scp-321 to be removed from
scp status on the basis that it was
unnecessary all were denied by the o5
council years later adam had been
promoted to personal director at site-04
he again requested scp-321 to be
released from containment and was again
given a firm no but a father's love
never goes away as he kept being
promoted he kept requesting his daughter
be freed into his custody when he became
site director of site-04 just as you had
joined the foundation he made a
statement declaring that there was
nothing more the foundation had to learn
from scp-321
and that it should be released but again
nothing but denial and when he was
promoted to 05-12
he ordered that scp-321 be released and
returned to her family that's right
05-12 the old man standing beside you is
the same man that fathered and created
scp-321
so many years ago and that's not all
either his name is adam bright father of
notorious researcher dr jack bright
otherwise known as scp-963
the bright family's history is
intertwined with that of the scp
foundation but despite all their power
they cannot get one of their own
released from the foundation's cells
when o5-12 made the decree 05-1
addressed him personally he was told
that scp-321 was not his daughter if she
ever had been and that if he requested
her release again he would be dismissed
from the o5 council since then all he
has been able to do is visit his little
girl deep beneath site-04 and protect
her from further experimentation he
explains that he hides and classifies
her existence so heavily to make sure no
one tries to perform more tests and take
advantage of her healing factor that's
why you were unable to access or even
figure out what the anomaly was for so
many years all the two of you can do is
stand next to the hospital bed the
history of the scp foundation is a long
and twisted one especially considering
the complex web of relationship between
its employees the extensive bright
family headed by famous jack bright but
containing many of his relatives winds
through the foundation when one of its
members abuses their position you've
seen how terrible the results can be as
for scp-320
some anomalies tragically can't be saved
and there's little the foundation can do
about that now go check out scp immortal
dr bright explained and dr bright for
president
scp-4444 bush vs gore for more on the
fascinating intricacies of the infamous
dr jack bright